hello and welcome to our to the third
episode of our show about games
my name is Bruno Oliveira and I work in
the Android developer relations team
I am Todd Kerpelman I am on the Play
games developer relations team and this
is episode 3 of game on are sort of
every couple of weekly show about all
things games related and you're probably
wondering where episodes 1 & 2 went and
this is what we're going to talk about
this brings us right into our news and
updates and we'll start with we actually
changed our name we have a name we used
to be the Google Play game show and now
we've changed to game on actually that
that looks a little too modern to
my taste why don't we try something more
Rito like eight bits ah that's that's
that's much better that's a little
bigger that's a little better
you'll notice we added the lens flares
in just for you gamers we hope you love
lens flares and we have some news on the
iOS Franta teaser right that's right on
the iOS front the big news is we just
released an update to the iOS SDK
version 1.1 is officially available the
biggest improvement that you will
probably notice is that we have a new
look for the achievement and the
leaderboard widgets it's a little more
of a modern look kind of going with sort
of the the aesthetic of iOS moving
forward so you'll probably notice that
right away we also have a number of
performance improvements under the hood
we've greatly improved the caching for
leaderboard scores if for instance your
user switches back and forth between
daily weekly and all-time leader board
scores that will be much faster we do a
better job of batching and submitting
leaderboard scores if the user plays a
bunch offline then comes back online all
of their leaderboard scores all their
score submissions will be submitted in
one nice little batch instead of saying
multiple score submission so that'll be
nice that'll be a lot more efficient we
have exposed that call as well if you
want to for instance submit a couple of
scores to a couple of leaderboards all
at once we now
have a call available for you to
basically batch all those up and make
those in one Network call which is
really nice the kind of you know saves
on battery and performance and all of
that stuff we've also made just a number
of bug fixes and enhancements in in
general sort of performance improvements
under the hood and so we encourage you
to check it out I do want to let you
know about a couple of gotchas first
there are two new frameworks that are
required by this new library
specifically cortex framework and quartz
chord framework so if you haven't
included those in your project you'll
need to also with this new library
you're going to need a deployment target
of iOS 6.0 or greater chances are you're
probably already doing that with your
game but if not you are going to need to
change your deployment target if you're
using this new library and so this
library is available from our site at
developers.google.com/live for the
Downloads link on the left alright and
now for those of you who like tracking
bugs and especially like a public way to
track bugs we have tada a public bug
tracker so if you've got a bug or a
future request then you can access that
URL right there if it's
code.google.com/speed a games platform
this is also available from our games
page if you look on the left there is
now a link to I believe public bug
tracker so if you notice any issues with
the game or you have requests or
anything else feel free to omit them
there I can't I can't guarantee that we
will reply to every bug but I can't
guarantee we'll at least look at them
absolutely and make sure - I mean to
post only the bugs I have to do with the
platform there if you have a bug if you
find a bug in the samples and then the
right place is the github yeah go to
github and there github has its own a
show system and yeah if you find a bug
with a game you're still probably better
off contacting the game developer
exactly we can't debug every game we
didn't make every game know so with that
out of the way let's move into this
week's topic which is cloud save and so
cloud save is a really I think it's a
great feature
I think this service is a little
underutilized right so it's missing on
so many games like
I've lost count how many times I've
played a game and wished it had clouds
say yeah I mean if you like if you
change devices and then have to lose all
of your progress
I suppose Google employees might have
more devices than your typical consumer
but even now you're starting to see
consumers with a lot of devices in the
household right like maybe they've got
more than one phone maybe they've got a
phone and a tablet and they switch back
and forth between them and it would be
great for your users if they could keep
their progress between you know one
device and the next if they suddenly you
know go from playing your game on their
phone to opening up your game on the
tablet and they realize that they have
to start over again all the way from
level one they're probably just not
going to play your game on that on that
device and you know maybe suddenly they
decide they've lost interest in it you
know they're not playing your game
anymore they're not seeing ads they're
not buying in-game items they're not
telling their friends about it and you
know it's it's it's bad for for your
users and it's bad for you too
so we really encourage you to look into
cloud save it's really just designed to
do one thing and one thing only and
that's kind of sync your users progress
from one device to the next and so with
that big preamble out of the way let's
go into a demo actually before we go
into the demo it's important to notice
that a cloud save is actually
cross-platform
so you can even have again if your game
runs on Android and iOS I mean you can
save your state on Android and then pick
up the same state where they left off on
iOS or vice-versa so that's good for
households that have like one iPad and
then one Android and one iPhone and then
another Android so that is very true I
mean that's starting to become a common
situation households will have you know
Android phones and iPads or they'll have
you know a nexus 7 and iPhone and being
able to play your game and continue
progress between those devices what
would really be fantastic and if your
game also works on the web you can also
share that state on the web so that's
pretty handy that is very true too all
right so with that in mind we're gonna
be demoing samurai vs Zombies defense -
this is by Glu Mobile partly because
it's a it's a pretty good example of
cloud save event also because and also
because it has samurais and songs and
zombies nothing at all with that
yeah and it's a pretty fun game
so with that it's gonna jump into this
is the this is the game right now
running on this is a Galaxy Nexus with
my Galaxy Nexus phone and I'm not I
would love to show you more of the game
but we're limited in time so I'm just
gonna do something real quick here I'm
going to start the game up and the game
starts me in a storefront and so I think
oh oh do I want to download this game
not right now but thanks for thanks for
asking alright so I'm actually just
gonna you'll notice I have 920 of these
little silver coins I'm gonna use them
to upgrade this hero here kunoichi from
from level 1 to level 2 so yes let's
upgrade her health all right all right
she's been upgraded now I'm gonna go
back to the main menu and the game does
save to the cloud automatically however
because we're in a demo situation I'm
going to manually enforce a save so it's
gonna say ok I'm gonna save to the cloud
next that's next chance I have and
hopefully it's doing that right now
alright now let's let's switch to our
tablet and see if that worked
alright so I'm on the I'm on the Nexus
10 now and I'm just gonna force a cloud
load here by going into the cloud load I
mean you notice that normally this would
happen automatically we're just forcing
it so that we can actually do this in
that in a demo time frame instead of
sitting around waiting for it to load
but normally this the user would would
not have to do this so now we're loading
the game again so remember that Todd
upgraded the character on the Galaxy
Nexus so what we should see when the
game loads is that the character is
gonna be upgraded so we should see a
higher level character should see that
work fingers crossed
yep let's see here I'm gonna start and
and there we go yep so same level level
3 you are level 3 before it well yeah or
I guess level 2 that option is to
upgrade to level 3 oh yeah
point being it's a my progress is
carried over from one device to the next
and now I can keep playing
on the Nexus 10 which actually is a much
better framerate so this is a this is a
better platform to play on anyway yep so
I'm just gonna take this with me after
the show okay so there we go alright so
conflict management
so cloud safe I mean it's it's pretty
convenient it can save and it can load
but then imagine what happens if two
devices try to save conflicting states
at the same time to the cloud so I'm
playing here on my tablet and then I
upgrade my character to level 2 and then
on my phone I upgrade the same character
to level 4 without sinking sinking up
the changes what's gonna happen is
what's called the carb save conflict so
you need to think about those save
conflicts and then handle them in a way
that makes sense for your app so if you
wanna take a look this is that link over
there is a link to to a white paper that
we wrote that talks about how many
strategies to handle clouds of conflicts
and how to make that in a way that makes
sense and that especially and this is
especially important in a way that
doesn't lose any progress for the user
right so it's a it's a pretty in-depth
bit of bitter reading my takeaway if you
just want some general advice is when
you're trying to resolve to cloud saves
resolve these two states in isolation
don't assume based on sort of the local
users game state or anything you know
more than in sort of what you get from
the cloud save data just because you
it's it gets a little tricky but due to
some times the way we give you these two
states to resolve they might not be
actually in the the timeframe that you
expect so long long story short try and
reserve these try and resolve these two
states as if this is the only data you
have and just try and forget about the
rest of the world when you're when
you're doing that and I suppose there's
there's a couple ways you can kind of
look at this problem one way is you know
if you want to be clever do it do it
Bruno's way would be you can you can
essentially just you can look at the be
the two states and see if there's a
clever way in which you can merge them
together instead of just picking one or
the other sometimes it might just make
sense to pick one or the other but
sometimes if you notice that they have
discrepancies it might make sense to
sort of like merge them intelligently
together so this is what for instance
sample collect all the stars do does
which is for instance if you unlock a
few levels on one device and then I look
at different set of levels on different
device then what it does is it actually
combines those two saves into one it
doesn't choose one doesn't choose the
other but actually combines them into a
single save that has all of those levels
unlocked so yeah if you think about a
lot of games you know cut the rope Angry
Birds where's my where's my water
where's my Mickey which is awesome you
know if you think about the way those
games work in general you know you have
stars on every level and you have high
scores on each level and that can be
pretty safely Union between two
conflicting sets of data right if you
have you know two stars on level one
four on this device and three stars and
level one four in this other device
that's something you can very easily
merge just by saying let's let's take
the greater number of stars yeah but be
careful about stars may may be an easy
case but be careful about stuff like the
virtual currency and stuff like that
because it can get actually into into
into too hard to predict problems so the
more details about that in the and the
white paper and then of course if you
don't want to be clever just asking the
user say hey you know what we found
these two sets of cloud data this one
looks like it was saved on you know July
30th on this device and this one looks
like it was saved on August 1st you know
at this time on this device you're at
level you know for with a thief on on
this one and you're at level 5 with a
paladin on this device which one do you
really want you know ask we user bring
up the dialogue chances are the user
will know which one they want examine
and go with what they pick yep so if you
want more information check the docs you
probably knew we were going to say that
but but there's the there say that on
every show we kind of do like go to the
doc is all go or not we we spent a lot
of time on them you should read them we
have a link to cloud save they're on you
know sort of general concepts you can
read up more about it read Bruno's white
paper yeah and if of course if you are
if you want some real excitement you can
try out of sample app just collect all
the stars and we have versions for
collect all the stars on Android iOS and
web so you can you can see what it looks
like saving one state from on one device
and another state another completely
different device
watching your progress carryover it's
it's pretty much and it's a very
challenging game it is so so yeah that
too so I think that pretty much wraps it
up for episode three of game on we'll be
back in a couple of weeks with episode
four and we'll probably keep the same
title so just start start searching for
it alright so thanks everybody and see
you next time
thanks video audience